welcome everyone to the 2017
lecture as many of you know this is the
signature lecture series for the major
makes politics economics and this was
established thanks to the largesse of
John Castle who after who this was named
he'll be here with us tomorrow and I'll
tell you a little bit more about the
origin of this gift but the main event
is our speaker professor Catherine
stickings
the purpose of this lecture is to help
us think as a community about the
importance of ethical choices societies
individuals may in this complex world
and we have someone with us today who in
her own work has thought about these
questions for a couple of decades now
and so I just wanted to tell you a
little bit about her work she's the Ryan
family professor of human rights policy
at the Harvard Kennedy School the
Carroll k4 timer professor at the
Radcliffe Institute for Advanced Study
and she is really the the scholar who
has had the most to say I think about
what you would call social
entrepreneurship about the importance of
changing the way people average ordinary
people think about ethically important
questions is a way to move our
governments to behave in a way that they
otherwise might not and so she's going
to give three lectures today tomorrow
and Wednesday
all of them in sort of extending her
thinking about ethics in public life
across a range of issues and so I'll
just turn the floor over to Catherine
because she has so much to say and I
hope you will come back tomorrow in the
next day as well well first Thank You
Francis and thanks to the castle lecture
committee which I presume there's a
lecture committee for this great honor
it's actually a great honor to be chosen
to give these lectures and thanks to all
of you for being here as well and in
these I'm using these lectures as an
opportunity really to think about an
entirely new project and it's a project
and as I call about rediscovering
individual responsibility in the age of
Rights and I actually came upon this
topic almost by accident in doing the
research for the my last book that just
came out and as I dug into it I
discovered that it was more important
and more controversial than I originally
understood and it was important because
the topic of rights and responsibilities
helps us think about some of the most
pressing political issues of the day as
well as crucial debates on campus so
issues about climate change
gun violence our civic duty to vote the
right to free speech including protest
as well as responsibility to respect the
speech of others and I am going to argue
that people who work on human rights and
people who write about human rights have
long avoided using the language of
responsibilities individual
responsibilities and even more
the language of individual duties and
now I include myself in that group okay
I've been working off and on Human
Rights for about 37 years and if you and
I've written a lot about the topic and
if you've read what I've written you'll
see that I have not spoken
about I'm not written about
responsibility very little about
responsibility and almost nothing about
duty and I have lots of company ok even
contemporary thinkers who are
sympathetic to cosmopolitan ethics
expressed skepticism about
individualized obligations to promote
human rights so philosophers and I'm not
sure we have any philosophers in the
audience but philosophers and political
theorists of course have dealt with this
topic ok I have thought I think deeply
about a responsibilities and duties but
the folks who work more on human rights
law and particularly who work on the
politics with human rights and human
rights practice have tended to avoid
discussions for individual
responsibilities and duties so much so
that I would say some writers and
activists are so focused on rights that
they sometimes bend over backwards to
frame everything in a using a rights
language rather than speak of
responsibilities and I'm going to be
talking today about partly about
environmental issues and environmental
activists are increasingly talking about
rights as a way to frame the environment
ok our right to a clean environment the
right of tweeze I know that sounds but
there's a famous Law Review article
that's been extremely well sited about
the right of trees the rights of rivers
the rights of Earth mother herself in
Latin America in Bolivia Ecuador this
called the the law of Pachamama that's
the Quechua name for the earth mother
right and so there's all these ways of
thinking about rights and the
environment and so an environmental
group brought a recent loss group in
Colorado to give the Colorado River
legal rights if they succeed the
Colorado River will join a small handful
of other rivers that have legal rights
including the Ganges River no I am NOT
opposed to rivers trees or the earth
mother herself having rights but I think
it's more practical
and straightforward to stress directly
the responsibility of states
corporations and individuals to protect
trees rivers or the environment more
generally so my purpose here is not to
argue against rights people who know me
know that I have long been a firm
defender of Rights but I am doing
something new I'm doing something new
for me and even something risky for me
and that is I want to talk about how we
need to bring responsibilities more
firmly back into discussions around
rights and so it's not the either/or
model it's not either rights or
responsibilities it's the both and both
rights and responsibilities now this is
not only for progressives conservatives
also often place too much of a stress on
rights such as the right to bear arms
such as the right to religion but not on
the individual duties and
responsibilities that must accompany
such rights so that guns do not endanger
our society and the way we just saw in
Los Angeles excuse me on Las Vegas or
that the right to religion doesn't lead
to discrimination and violence so let me
just briefly sketch how I want to handle
this issue over three days I'm thinking
that as three concentric circles the
first circle the starts with the
broadest type of rights and
responsibilities to the global order so
issues like climate change or
environmental change are genuinely
global problems and require global
responsibilities that's kind of today
tomorrow I'm going to go down to the
next circle which I'm going to think
more about civic rights and
responsibilities within the nation-state
and particularly I want to talk about
the civic responsibility to vote and
then on Wednesday I'm going to come down
further and talk about issues that are
very big issues on our campuses today
and certainly they are at Harvard I know
they are here at Yale there those are
national international issues as well
but I want to think a little about them
as as as campus issues and the issues of
the right to speech the right to protest
and also the reason
possibility if not to respect the speech
of others at least not to drown it out
so in these talks I'm going to use a
human rights term broadly to refer to
economic social political and civil
rights that are in the universal
declaration of human rights as well as
the rights new rights like the right to
a clean environment and you know there's
unlimited responsibilities we could talk
about and my discussion of possibilities
is is geared to right so I'm interested
in those responsibilities that are
essential and are linked to the
fulfillment of Rights
now I argue that human rights people
have largely seated or relinquished the
discussion about responsibility
individual responsibility mainly to
others and I think mainly to
conservatives in part when we spoke when
we speak of responsibility it used to be
responsibility for others and now
there's been a turn in the way we talk
in this country about responsibility and
it's increasingly become responsibility
as okay as there's a new book
Jasha Monk and I'm sure that's how you
pronounce that yashka monk has reminded
us here's a new book called the age of
responsibility and he has said that that
today when we talk about responsibility
were mainly focused on on an
individual's transportation for him or
herself in the context of a restricting
welfare state
okay so this so we've transmog says we
transform from sponsibility being what
you do for others to being what you
should do for yourself but that is a
more punitive and I think a narrow
understanding responsibility I believe
that responsibly has potential to
provoke a far richer debate that's
intensely relevant for human rights and
this Richard about responsibilities that
I want to explore with you over the next
few days so monk has argued that
thirty years quote the notion of
personal responsibility has become
central to our moral and political
discourse into our actual public
policies it's no exaggeration he argues
to say that we now live in an age of
responsibility but if we take at least a
quick and dirty view using Google Ngram
view of responsibilities compared to
rights and duties I don't you can all
see rights are the Greenline duties the
blue responsibilities I'm not sure if
you're all familiar with the Google
Ngram this is the the appearance of
certain words certain phrases and words
in books okay over a long period of time
but what we see is that compared to
rights talk responsibility and Duty talk
is still much more limited and so I'm
not convinced yet that we're in an age
of responsibility at least it with
reference to to rights and that's why
I've entitled this rediscovering
responsibility in the age of rights I'd
argue we're in the age of rights and
even if we do this is if we take you
know you need to if you take two words
here human rights and personal
responsibility you find that you know
they were kind of linked together until
1940 and at least using the double word
here in in grams we do not see a
dramatic increase in in notions of
personal responsibility so no it would
be useful to find other measures of this
and I hope to do that in the future so
this is just a kind of a quick and dirty
starting place but at but I think it's
it's a it's an interesting place to
start and I'll be interested in hearing
from you what would be other good ways
that one could measure discourses of
rights and and duties but for the time
being I I'm not yet seeing evidence that
we live in an age of responsibilities
but I do agree with monk that we need to
reclaim and find a positive view of
responsibility monk has done this as a
political theorist in the Khan
to us debate over welfare policy I try
to to do it as a social working social
scientist who does work on broader human
rights debate on the issue
responsibility been very influenced by
hunter rents understanding of political
responsibility especially in her book
Eichmann in Jerusalem and the parts of
that book that have always most
captivated me are not the ones about
guilt they're the ones about positive
responsibility and particularly her
stories about the the importance of the
Danish case of the Danish government and
Danish citizens who took political
responsibility for the rescue of Jews in
Denmark and protected the great great
majority of the Jews in Denmark from
deportation to death camps at one point
of rent said I thinks that the Danish
case should be required reading for
every political scientist to talk about
the great power of nonviolent resistance
and political responsibility and I agree
with her and in fact for many years I
made it required reading for any
political scientist who took my human
rights class but today I also have been
very very influenced since I agreed to
do that the more influenced by iris
Marion Young's book responsibility for
justice and in particular she has a
notion she calls a social connection
model of responsibilities whereby
everyone who is connected to a problem
not just people who are liable for it
who are to blame for it but people are
connected to it and are able to act need
to step forward and take action to to
work in concert to solve problems of
structural injustice now today I want to
present what I call some puzzles and
some paradoxes about responsibilities
and the first puzzle I call the mystery
of the missing duties in April of 1948
21 states of the Americas gathered
together in Bogota Colombia
and they produce the first
intergovernmental Declaration of Rights
the American Declaration of Rights and
duties of man notion the American
Declaration of Rights and duties of man
okay
this as the title indicates this
provided a clear place for putting
duties individual duties right alongside
rights and but those duties did not get
incorporated into later human rights law
and so that's my mystery what happened
to the duties that were present in the
American Declaration why didn't they go
into later human rights law now the
American Declaration was it really
should be called the Latin American
Declaration there were 20 Latin men
countries and the United States the
United States did not participate
actively in the drafting of the American
Declaration everyone thinks that the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights is
the first intergovernmental Declaration
of Rights but of the first inter
government declaration of the
International protection of Human Rights
but it's not the American Declaration
was drafted circulated and approved a
full eight months before the Universal
Declaration anyone who wants to go into
the deep history we can talk about it
but basically the full draft of the
American Declaration was circulated
among among the countries of the region
before the group that drafted the
Universal Declaration had its first
meeting okay so this is truly was the
first integral declaration and yet Latin
Americans never give credit for it not
only that like Holly various colleagues
continued to talk about human rights is
something that comes only from the
global north and is imposed upon the
global South against their will okay and
unfortunately some of the people who
make that argument and sometimes do it
in the name of the people of the global
South have ironically not bothered to
read the archives from the global South
and especially they haven't bothered to
read about the American Declaration of
Rights and duties of man my my issue
today though is not about a cultural
Human Rights is cultural
realism that's another talk my issue
today is about the duties in the
American Declaration okay so the
American Declaration has ten duties
these are not these are just this
shortened the truncated version of those
of those duties that they're each a long
article but the the first the first duty
list in the American Declaration is the
duty the individual to conduct himself
in relation to others so that each and
every one may fully form and develop his
personality so this provision could be
read as a responsibility to respect the
rights of others but in context and it
seems to support a more ambitious claim
that of an individual responsibility to
ensure the full development of potential
that lies in others okay and then you
see these are the other duties that are
in the American Declaration now the
American Declaration has been recognized
by scholars including people like
Johannes Moore sink and Marian Glendon
as a really important influence on the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
but all the rights in the American
Declaration go into the inertial
declaration none of the duties and so
the question is what happened in the
missing duties so this is what you know
the universal equation has only one line
on duties and this is it article 29 now
when drafting the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights the delegates managed to
get duties entirely taken out of the
draft document and they they got down to
this and I'll tell you a little later
about how they managed to do that
but after duties failed to get into the
inertial declaration then they did not
move into any other piece of human
rights law with the single exception of
the African Convention of Human and
people's rights and so this might be
what's called what political science is
called a path dependent a situation it
could just be that that once it was in
the nurse'll Declaration the path was
set for how you write human rights
declarations of human rights law and it
was not to include individual duties
but I think that I think there's a
deeper puzzle here because and that I
want to explore later the second puzzle
I have for you is that human rights
advocates are among the people most
motivated personally motivated by a
strong sense of ethical political
responsibility towards victims of human
rights violations so when you speak to
human rights advocates and I've spoken
to many in my lifetime I've interviewed
hundreds of advocates what gets them up
in the morning is not primarily a sense
of anger against injustice though that
is also there but it's deep sense of
personal responsibility to do something
about it yet these individual
responsibilities though deeply felt are
mainly not stated one friend who's now
retired done a lot of work on human
rights and democracy I asked him that
question I asked about responsibility
and he said this quote responsibility is
like breathing
I felt duty-bound to take action but I
never used the word responsibility I
never had the consciousness to think
about it in those terms he went on to
say and when people are on the fence you
have to lead by example not by preaching
duty and if I did try people might say
to me who are you to tell me what to do
so here's a theme that emerges that's
gonna reappear again in these next
couple of days and that is the
discomfort the discomfort human rights
advocates feel when they talk about
individual responsibility of to others
almost in the end the aversion to
preaching so scholars have drawn some
parallels between human rights and
secular religion infects a Moyne who's
at the law school here now has drawn
this parallel between the modern
humorous movement as a secular religion
okay but in this case we have Hume
rights activists they're happy to preach
the duty of state they they're happy to
preach the the power of rights and the
duty of states but they do not want to
preach about individual responsibility
of others even though they themselves
are motivated by such responsibility
and in the 70s and 80s human rights
activists were organizations were famous
for actually being so committed to their
responsibilities that they had they they
mistreated their staff there were the
40-hour work we didn't exist no paid
vacations these are people who often
were experiencing secondary trauma but
until today we organisations we're not
getting them the psychological support
that they needed so we actually have
situations that people are sometimes
making themselves physically ill by
acting on their sense of responsibility
yet it was still largely unspoken no
finally I want to draw attention to a
paradox that I found so I've given you
two puzzles and now a paradox the
products is this is that when I draw
attention that there's this view of
responsibilities are simultaneously
ubiquitous and dangerous so what do I
mean by ubiquitous and dangerous many
legal scholars including I suspect some
sitting in the room right now will say
to me duties are not missing at all when
I presented a preliminary version of
this paper to my legal colleagues they I
got two main messages one message was I
had simply misunderstood if I had really
taken a law degree I would know that
duties are ubiquitous they are
everywhere implied every time you say
you have a right it implies the duty
usually a duty of a state but maybe a
duty of an individual but I was still
puzzled if it's so obvious that all
lawyers know it at least why is it that
the state's actually felt the need to
take duties out of the universal
declaration okay it didn't make the art
it they didn't make the argument duties
were obvious but that they were somehow
problematic okay and then some of these
same legal colleagues sometimes taking
me aside would say and besides it's
dangerous to talk about duties and so
there's the paradox in the sense of a
kind of an apparently self contradictory
statement how could duties be everywhere
so present as
not even be worthy of mentioning and the
same time dangerous now I thought there
was a quirk of the scholars I was
talking to but I just two months ago I
tended to workshop in Norway and I was
talking to a colleague a lawyer as well
and she said what do you do and I said
I'm preparing the talk for Yale about
human rights and human responsibilities
and she didn't miss a beat she goes well
that's dangerous I and I like I can't
believe I'm ocean away and I'm hearing
this dangerous stuff again so now I knew
I said why is it dangerous so she gave
me the answer similar to monk's answer
it's dangerous because if the
Conservatives have co-opted the language
of responsibility and we can't use it
without somehow legitimating that
version so so but I I think it's
actually more complicated in that and
these are some of my thoughts about why
duties might be seen as dangerous or why
at least that might be certain
discomfort for human rights people
around duties so when when delegates
were first drafting the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights Charles
Malik made an impassioned plea to
exclude duties from the from the
declaration okay Malik was a Lebanese
delegate to the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights drafting committee he was a
Maronite Christian he did his doctorate
at Harvard and one author has called him
quote an existentialist philosopher
turned master diplomat he was one of the
four most important people involved in
drafting mistral Declaration of Human
Rights in 14 1947 he was responding to a
draft of the Universal Declaration the
so called Secretariat draft they could
have been written in the in the
secretary's office and Malick said dr.
Nagy said it was quote astounding that
the first articles of the draft
declaration should state that quote
everyone owes a duty to his state he
questioned whether an individual would
such a duty of loyalty regardless of the
characters of his state suggesting an
authoritarian state for example was not
entitled to any duty or loyalty malik
argued that it was quote precisely
because the balance
been tipped against the individual and
in favor of society that human rights
have been violated for mallik speaking
of duties was about duties to the state
and due to the state were old and
dangerous and the idea led to human
rights violations not to improvement now
and this is kind of the cut I think in
1947 Malick was right okay that just at
the moment when the rights of human
rights were being declared the
International protection of human rights
was being declared for the first time it
didn't make sense to come back to this
old language of duties and specially
duties to the state but were seventy
years later now and the international
production of Rights has grown from
those first innovative declarations to a
large complex of international meit's
law multiple institutions to enforce
that law human rights are now one of the
dominant moral discourses of our age the
balance that Malick spoke of has been at
least rhetorically tipped in the favor
of Rights in this context it may make
sense to think of tipping the balance
again by adding individual
responsibilities more explicitly back in
the mix why because the lawyers are
correct insane that responsibilities are
obvious in the sense that it only makes
sense to say you have a right if there's
a correlative duty or responsibility the
rights movement however it has fixated
on state duty and now today but
increasingly on corporate the duties of
corporations so the fashionable thing to
do nowadays is to work on duties of
corporations but some rights to be
genuinely enjoyed require Network duties
by all those connected and including
individuals and I think we've reached an
impasse of sorts on some rights where we
need to stress rights and
responsibilities to see our way through
now Malick wasn't alone he was supported
by the government's United States United
Kingdom who brought with them an
anglo-american tradition that was simply
less sympathetic to duties okay so the
us contribute
to debate stressed quote the exercise of
rights in the exercise of his rights
everyone is limited by the rights of
others this is as opposed to the rights
and duties tradition of Latin America
this is the rights vs. rights tradition
that I think the anglo-american rights
vs. rights tradition okay so individual
rights are only limited by the rights of
others not by a duty to respect rights
and I actually think it's particularly
this anglo-american Edition that's
gotten out of balance so I'm arguing
that stressing duties of continents to
rights could be a tool to address global
challenges we've already talked about
the environment but we could also talk
about issues like the you know issues
like for example problems of the refugee
issue right when we're talking about
refugees it's important not just to talk
about the duties of States to receive
refugees it's important also to talk
about the duty of communities the
responsibility of communities to to help
the state receive refugees and even to
talk about responses of refugees to make
a life in a new country if we're talking
about confronting economic inequality
it's necessary to talk about the rights
of individuals to an adequate center of
living and the duties of individuals to
pay taxes so that a government can
address poverty and inequality at home
and abroad it's again it's become really
fashionable led by our current president
to act that only stupid people pay taxes
the whole notion of a civic
responsibility pay taxes has become demo
day but in in a world where all economic
and social rights depend on available
resource of government governments say
we don't have available resources and
yet we know that the available resources
are there but are not being attacked for
a government Paulo
see and even something like the you know
let's say the education of girls and
women in the world it's not enough just
to say the state needs to build schools
or needs to change its laws we have to
talk responsibility parents teachers
schools communities and states to create
the conditions under which that right
can be fulfilled
okay so I've already suggested some
reasons why why duties might be seen as
dangerous I want to just quickly
synthesize them in a few bullet points
the perception that conservatives have
monopolized the term right and this many
feel that term responsibilities become
to be a way of blaming victims for their
own misfortunes and so if human rights
people use a term it inevitably carries
that baggage monke describes this he
says in response the left has come
forward with what monk calls the no
responsibility view okay and that is
that but people who receive wealth for
example have no responsibility for their
position because they couldn't have
avoided it it was their situation is so
deeply structural so do you resolve the
structure a bit of capitalism or of our
system here that that the that that
people should be seen as having no
responsibility among human rights
activists there's some of this no
responsibility thinking with regard to
victims indeed that the proper attitude
human rights is to see the victim as
without responsibility this is so much
the case is a really interesting debate
nowadays where victims don't want to be
called victims because if you're a
victim not only do you not have
responsibility but you don't have agency
and so you have the mover people say no
we're not victims we're survivors of
torture of sexual abuse whatever because
it's a way to maintain their agency in
that situation and I think perhaps also
maintain something connected agency
which is responsibility but I disagree
with monk that the no response review is
somehow more associated with the left I
here in the left I know the left does it
I know the human rights movement does it
but as I suggested earlier I think
the right is doing it every bit as much
and that with the example of gun
violence being the most prominent
right so we do not here even though gun
violence country has reached a level of
a huge social injustice we don't hear
enough about the duties of owners of
guns the state the gun industry gun
store owners and everyone else connected
socially connected to gun violence of
how what we're going to do to be able to
to bring this or to address the
situation but what we know is the
language of rights is utterly
insufficient by itself to address it
likewise when Jack Phillips the owner of
masterpiece cake shop in Lakewood
Colorado refused to do a wedding cake
for a gay couple there because of his
right to religion he stressed only his
right to religion but not his not any
personal ethical or legal responsibly
not to discriminate once again all the
weight falls on my right not on my
responsibilities so now whenever I start
talking about this my colleagues get
anxious right because they're saying
you're you're say you're talking too
much about individual agency and you're
Noreen structural or systemic processes
that cause human rights violations right
and you know and because there's
structural causes we're going to need
you know very powerful responses and
often the notion and only radical change
for example in the nature of capitalism
is sufficient to address these human
rights violations but that's why I find
Irish Jung's position so compelling
because instead of a no responsibility
view it proposes a broader and deeper
understanding of responsibility more
responsibility not no responsibility
okay
third I think there's a worry that that
that responses and duties is a way to
smuggle in
religious sentiment or traditional
communitarian beliefs into the human
rights language so one explanation for
why duties didn't go from the American
Declaration into the Universal
Declaration is that that some delegates
were worried that the this the duties in
the American Declaration came from
Catholic Social Doctrine and it was a
way of kind of smuggling Catholic social
doctrine in to the Universal Declaration
now the I know from the research the
duties in the American Declaration are
some are indeed in part from Catholic
Social Doctrine okay but they have two
other sources as well
one important source is is socialist
thought okay so this is back in Mia
forty-eight we have Guatemala under a
devil oh just has a radical new
constitution and they are proposing
duties that come out of their socialist
vision the main a group that the main
delegate that drafted it was a Mexican
delegate and he took his ideas of duties
from the Mexican constitution of 1917
was considered a radical Constitution at
a time it had a lot of economic and
social rights as well as these duties
and it was an anti clerical government
okay so this idea that somehow this is
only religion misses the boat and
finally in the Americas both north and
south there is a civic Republican vision
of that that also calls for more
attention to responsibilities and duties
so okay and you know finally there's
this there's this worry and I think this
is what Malick suggested that focus on
duties could take or could lead us to
take away rights and it has take this
worry has taken a very modern form
recently again when I presented this to
some legal colleagues they said well
what about dignity I'm not going dignity
I'm not sure what dignity has to do as
France abilities and they said well what
about the dwarf-tossing case which I
didn't know about the time but I do know
about now
and so there's a relatively obscure case
of the human rights committee the case
wacken hem verse V France the so called
dwarf-tossing case has taken on
importance well beyond its narrow
confines okay
because it is seen as creating a
precedent that states could be permitted
to deny rights to individuals because
those individuals are not acting in the
name of their own responsibility to
protect their own dignity you know that
sounds but so it may sound far-fetched
you listen ok dwarfing want
dwarf-tossing apparently started in
Australia in bars and discotheques and
it involves contestants who see how far
they can throw and hear a quote we're a
willing and suitably protected dwarf the
farthest into a padded landing stage ok
now New York City prohibited dwarf
toffee in 1990 Florida did as well and
so did France mr. Wacken ham a French
citizen argued that the law quote
infringed on his autonomy in his right
to pursue employment in a difficult job
market the human rights committee found
however that it was contrary to his
dignity to sell himself in a
dwarf-tossing and upheld the French law
I'm sure there was a margin some kind of
margin of appreciation there too people
are worried about this case because
particularly for what it will foreshadow
and I think particularly what it's been
a foreshadow about sex work right if a
dwarf cannot sell himself into tossing
in it's not far some reason before
people were not permitted as a matter of
responsibility for their own dignity to
sell themself into sex work and so
there's this sort of new anxiety as well
about responsibilities that focus that I
think on a quite narrow set of issues
which is responsibility one has to
oneself in one's own dignity that's
still you know kind of stirring up
stirring up the waters here so what is
my response to this list of dangers and
discomforts of duties
first and here for my legal colleagues I
want to say I'm not interested in
creating more legal responsibilities
okay
I'm not arguing we should open up any
human rights law and somehow renegotiate
it so that we have legal
responsibilities I'm speaking entirely
about ethical and political
responsibilities and I'm using political
in the tradition of a rent to think of
politics as a process we use of shaping
our world now to signal the shift I'm
going to I'm going to shift now entirely
to speak of responsibilities and not of
duties for the rest of the lectures
there's differences about there's people
differ about the precise meaning of duty
responsibilities but some consensus that
Duty implies are more legal and/or
precise obligations
iris Jung makes an interesting
distinction between responsible and Duty
argument responsibility conceptually is
more open and discretionary she says
this quote it is up to the agents who
have a responsibility to decide what to
do to discharge it within the limits of
other moral considerations and I think
that's a very useful interesting idea
that I want to come back and we talked a
little more about climate change and
that is that that you know they're not a
single path by through which individuals
discharge responsibility so I want to
speak here than a turning to Iris Jung's
model of social responsibility okay and
her social connection model
responsibility so I was young with a
socialist feminist theorist her last
work was responsible for justice the one
I'm using it was actually not quite
finished when she died and was finished
by a colleague and published it has been
seen in different ways some people see
it as some totally moving away from her
previous work but others see it as a
practical application of her more
theoretical ideas and a movement from
critique to reform or to some concrete
proposals for change now she
um I she does a couple things one is she
said when people think responsibility
they almost always think of the
liability model responsibility they
think of the legal model I think of
blame who is to blame who is at fault
who could be sued or who can be put in
prison for it and and she says I in this
particular case I'm not mainly
interested in liability model and like
young I do not believe that we should
replace or reject a liability model I
wrote a whole book two books ago called
the justice cascade where I talked about
the importance of individual criminal
accountability for mass atrocity I
believe it's entirely important
appropriate to keep a whole area of
human rights where we have individual
criminal accountability from for a gross
violation of human rights but I believe
that there are whole set of human rights
issues where the liability model doesn't
get us very far and or the individual
criminal accountability may be only one
small part of the solution and instead
we need to look at this social
connection model it's better because
before I encountered the social
connection model I had written I'd
written my first article on duties I've
written him with a co-author said of non
nobody on the VA who I want to recognize
his contributions to my research and my
thought on this issue came out in the
Minnesota Journal international law
anyone who's interested in a long
somewhat dry but very well footnoted
article about the deep history of duties
in human rights law as well as in
constitutions we do a quantitative count
of how where and how duties what duties
appear in constitutions in what
countries and regions of the world it's
not surprising that the region of the
world with most duties and the
constitutions is also Latin America but
any case I want to say I brought some
off prints and people aren't interested
you can help yourself to the off print
over there but the so we had already
used this phrase we called it Network
duties and it was getting a ton of some
of the same kinds of issues as a social
connection model and that is that
everyone connect
it's gonna have to step forward I prefer
now Young's notion of a social
connection model and that's the one I'm
now gonna if the language I'm going to
use but it's it's quite femoris I mean I
think that an under and I were sort of
stumbling towards with our networked
models of responsibility okay so so the
dilemma again when when I start
advocating this social connection model
people say yeah but if individuals get
involved it's gonna let the state get
off the hook and the state will not take
responsible for its what it needs to do
because individuals are stepping forward
and I again want to just tell a little
story because this took me back to many
years ago and I was I had a Latin
American friend visiting me in Minnesota
we were driving on the road and we saw
one of those ubiquitous signs you know
the Rotary Club is responsible for
cleaning off the the keeping clean the
roadside for the next two miles and my
friend said I hate those signs I hate
the whole concept because those people
are stepping forward and and letting the
steak off the hook the state should be
doing that and it's it's wrong that
individual step forward takes take off
the hook and at the time I mean having
you know we had a big discussion I felt
like this is virtually all of the litter
in that ditch has been thrown out by
individual drivers I can think of
nothing better than having the people
from the Rotary Club with their kids in
tow on a Saturday morning down there
picking up picking up garbage created by
individuals because at a minimum those
kids next time you know they want to
throw a candy wrapper out of the window
they're gonna think twice right and but
this also brought me to a much more
recent story that a friend my friend sue
told me from Gloucester and she said you
know used to be that the the state of
course the city of Gloucester put out
the receptacles on Good Harbor Beach and
but the best receptacles on a good beach
day got really full and but people kept
piling and piling into the port's
sitting at all on the sides of the
receptacle and ultimately you know the
tide came in and all that junk went out
because they they couldn't put it on
receptacles so the city Gloucester said
which is not putting receptacles on the
beach any more people are going to who
pack in their garbage you're going to
pack out their garbage and the beach got
a lot cleaner the point I want to make
with this is that sometimes this tension
between state response men in the
responsibilities is not so simple and
there may be some efficacies to getting
individuals involved in responsibility
for themselves right that it doesn't
what we shouldn't always assume the
state will do everything so my answer is
that sometimes we need to be
simultaneously concerned about state and
individual responsibility for ethical
reasons but also for the sometimes
surprising and counterintuitive efficacy
that a determined assertion of
individual response a can have now I'm
going to end with just a few remarks
about climate change and how my model
relates to climate change there's a huge
literature on climate epochs I can't
even begin to scratch the surface but
some of that literature is actually
drawing on something quite similar to
Iris Jung's idea of a social connection
model of responsibility so Jung believes
that we have responsibilities not
primarily by way of our membership in a
community that's what a rent said Jung
says no it's it has to go beyond just
being a member of put a community has to
be based on your your actual Ochs your
deeds deeds matter and response as a
matter of what we have and have not done
so for example in the area of of climate
change it calls on us to ask not just
what has a state done what have
corporations done but also what have we
done what of our deeds done with regard
to climate change and some authors
believe that if many more of us did this
over the course of a lifetime personal
emissions reductions in them
else could be substantial in addition
and their actual impact working on and
talking about response rate to reduce
our personal emissions could have
communicative value that increases their
efficacy so the crucial issue is that
this individuals ability must be
exercised in a collective manner right
it's not enough for us to work in
isolation we have to also work with
others to try to effect an overall
emission reduction our primary sponsors
but both of us to take action
individually and to make sure in
reaction is connected to broader efforts
to organize collectively and you know
virtually every author on this topic
acknowledges individuals have some duty
to promote collective action on the
environment so in this case we have to
ask us of hard questions about how to
reduce our carbon footprint and how to
organize collectively and particularly
this moment in our history at this
moment when our federal government has
stepped back out of taking and
responsibility for climate change it may
be a very important moment whereas we
know municipal governments and state
governments and individuals and other
communities are stepping forward to see
what they can do to exercise their
responsibilities in this context of the
federal state avoiding this
responsibility and here iris Young's
point that responsibility is more open
and discretionary as useful there's not
one way we need to refill we need to
fulfill our climate responsibility there
are multiple paths available to us my
own path is whenever I teach a global
citizenship I have my students and I do
our carbon footprint you ever done this
in class if you're a faculty member you
have to do it with your students and
your students of course come in most
students have incredibly small
footprints you know you and then so I
come in and I I calculate everything I'm
doing you know I'm I'm I live in a small
house at work I've added solar panels
I'm turning on the temperature I'm no
longer eating beef I'm composting and
recycling I'm walking
and biking but then I add in my
international and domestic airfare and
my my footprint goes crazy you know and
and basically you know a single
international air travel wipes out
everything I can do with composting and
a lot of my other efforts in a year so
my own personal struggle is with
international and domestic airfare and
that gets rid of kills and I just wrote
someone who invited me to Hong Kong I've
never been to Hong Hamin do internet
relations I've never been to China I
think I should go to China I'm thinking
this is crazy you know you fly across
the world just because as not because I
have a real research agenda there but
just because as an international
relations scholar I should go to China
and so I'm kind of I'm gonna agonizing
about it with my colleague in Hong Kong
and you know who writes back and sort of
says you know get a life he said you
know this is a concept I'm in doubt
lecture so so you don't come owned by
somebody else so some someone will take
the flight and he goes you should just
you know get that electric car you know
you you Americans I think so you just
get that electric car underway or
impeach your president so and you know I
again it but again he wants to say you
know he in some ways he's sort of
ridiculing the notion that there are
individual responsibilities and of
course we need to get the electric car
underway right and of course we need to
do something about our federal
government not doing its responsibility
with with climate change but that
doesn't mean that we all shouldn't be
grappling also with individual
responsibilities so just to conclude I'm
arguing that the world of human rights
which is a world in which I've devoted
much from my scholarship and my advocacy
the language of inner responsibilities
continues to be missing in an important
way
and at this moment a moment when human
rights discourses are both more powerful
than ever before and yet more under
attack than ever before this balance of
Rights this yin-yang of rights
responsibilities has gotten out of
balance
and we who believe in rights we're using
human rights comes as close as we can
come to a universal moral vocabulary and
legal system capable of addressing
repression and injustice we need to call
responsibility explicitly back into our
world of rights to bring that world back
into balance but exactly how and why to
do this and how it should be framed is
what I want to invite you to discuss
with me actually ask you to think out
loud
with me over these next three days
starting now with your comments and
questions there are risks and
discomforts perhaps even some dangers
but in the current context the risks of
inaction and complacency are often more
pressing than the risks of learning how
to balance responsibilities as crucial
complements to rights thank you okay so
I know we have a group of people who
have to leave so who told me ahead of
time but I so I'm just I'm serious I
want people to help me think a lot about
this this is as you know these cast
lectures get turned into books and I
really would would appreciate any
comments and suggestions or challenges
you have for me ya ona
clarification to some degree so part of
the reason event and we focused
primarily on rights language and the
human rights world is that a lot of
rights are covering the Universal
Declaration and that early treaties were
really negative rights as against the
state and that was partially a Western
u.s. agenda and if there was this would
you describe am it the kind of negative
rights versus positive rights view and
that the international community largely
kind of got going on the negative right
to you and there it makes sense and to
focus on rights as those
responsibilities do the right not to be
tortured you know to talk about
responsibility and the convicts that
torture doesn't kind of seems dissonance
right it doesn't it doesn't seem put
that in other than to put it in to state
responsibilities rights that
responsibility state not to engage in
torture there are the course of draft
articles on state responsibility which
is all about the ways in which the state
is responsible so you're right
say there's a language about
responsibility that's largely focused on
the state and whether in some ways what
you're reacting to or you're speaking to
and in some ways is the question in the
comment seems to be kind of a move
towards a different category topics so
you're not looking at climate change
that's kind of different from say
torture crimes against humanity your
crimes that kinds of things for the
state you know it's about what the state
is doing to me and I have the right to
tell the state not to do that thing to
me climate changes are a different
because of course yes there's obviously
a role for the state but the state has
to act by controlling the behavior of
individuals it's at the state of course
there's some kind of change control that
can happen through controlling the
actions of the state but a lot of it is
about how do you control to action the
individuals so all of a sudden now you
can't really tackle the problem without
talking about individuals and
responsibilities of individuals so it is
the conversation you're calling for not
so much like we messed up by failing to
talk about individual responsibilities
in the Human Rights
but that we're now to keep tackling a
different set of problems for which
simply talking about rates isn't enough
because you're not gonna get any we're
just talking about rights and just
talking about the state you've got to
start talking about getting individuals
involved and taking responsibility for
actions so I guess I'm just trying to
clarify it's not so much you're arguing
against the world yourself included was
wrong but they were now in a different
category or we're talking about
different kinds of things such that we
have to now bring in the language of
responsibility yes no I'm not saying
that the humor a somewhat messed up
which is actually why I said I thought
malloc in 1947 was right that we should
stress rights and not duties to the
state okay but then I said it's 70 years
later okay and yes there are some issues
and I think climate change is a good
example was actually why I started there
where the possibility of multiple actors
being connected to a problem and the
necessity of them taking action and
their ability to take action without the
state even if the state has retreated is
very high okay so we know actually
that's been you know what California
does is like really important for
climate change and even so so yes there
are some issues where that's more
obvious having said that i'm i'm it's
not your kind of classic so what are
some of the issues I'm gonna talk about
tomorrow my talk about that they're
responsible a to vote right and again
we've heard a lot about how we need to
struggle against voter suppression
struggling to state and I believe we
need to struggle against voter
suppression but the truth is we have a
bigger problem with non participation
than we even have with voter suppression
and I and I'm going to talk about that
or you know I'm gonna talk about speech
you know the right speech okay we can we
know that there is some suppression of
speech but we have this issue on campus
right is how do we exercise our right to
speech how do we protest and yet still
exercise responsibility for at least not
not blocking the speech of others so
yeah I promised
right so from the UK and specializing
actually in the rights of Mikey and
refugee children oh sorry yeah so UK
human rights lawyer specializing in
refugee and migrant children's rights
I wouldn't it if you'd looked at
children's rights law legal discourse
around children's rights particularly
around you know I mean one of the things
is but we found in practices you know
acting in the best interest of the child
most lawyers haven't got clue what that
means so so what does acting in the best
interest mean I mean now we've had
movement we've been moving on this and
there's now be the UN CRC general
comment 14 on what best interest means
and it's about the responsibilities of
schools you know if we're looking at
best at best interests we're also having
to consider the development and
well-being of the child and therefore
there is this I think a sense of the
need to think about who are the
professionals but also the actors in the
child's life so I just wouldn't it if
you heard right no one it's a terrific
point and I have looked at it and I'd
like you to send me the general comment
you just mentioned so the notion of
children up here is very early you see
that though that duties to children and
parents appear in the American
declaration also in the African
Convention okay and they come out of the
Mexican Constitution so here we're in
this revolutionary Mexican Constitution
and the first duties that talks about
and goes on at length is about the duty
to education and the duty to educate
your children and the in the duty of
parents for example not just to do to
the state the do the state the duty of
parents tend to get their children and
then the American declaration has an
interesting thing you have a duty to to
educate yourself so it's not these
sometimes duties are actually not just
the parents and the state and the school
and the community but actually children
have responsibilities and adults too as
you know have may have responsibilities
we may think of responsibilities for for
learning so I completely agree that
there may be the children would be
a special case where people honed in
very early on responsibilities yes was
afraid of responsibility Bushido was a
conservative idea but I thought it's
sort of walking jinhwan John Roma's idea
sort of appropriating the Antigua
latarian rights conception of
responsibilities in service of a leftist
case or redistribution so my question is
should your dukeship duties be conceived
on social security and welfare I'm
sitting here trying to find something
that works because I actually wanted to
put my in my uh yes good I wanted to put
my email address up here because you
just mentioned author I'm not familiar
with so I want I'm gonna ask people when
you give me ideas to uh to actually send
them to me if you don't mind okay at HKS
and I harvard.edu yeah I know to work in
but I don't know this particular piece
so I don't believe in peace you
mentioned so so yes this is the it's
particularly important the area of
becoming social rights and so I have
been thinking quite a lot about what I
said that you know yes you know the
Covenant Civil and you got a social
culture right talk to available
resources right government you know
throw up their hands and yet we know
that there's all sorts of ways that
available resources are there and are
being sucked out of countries via
corruption be illicit financial flows
tax havens
tax evasion tax avoidance etc okay so it
turns out that there we need actually
quite complex responsibilities to try to
figure out how to capture some of those
resources to put
to to bring them back into the provision
of state services second that can
contribute to economic and social rights
and I'm so I'm interested in you know in
pursuing these issues of what kinds of
policies could be taken to deal with
distributive justice I've only been
there for years
[Music]
it's in some ways taking ownership it
assumes it assumes choice this language
of structural conditions social science
from you about this dimension of
responsibility is a trait of character
that is connected with rights but to be
worthy of it means that you have to be a
certain so I do believe that
responsibilities may be related to
character having said that you're kind
of last second to last sentence is
exactly the sentence that's going to put
the human that's going to put the human
rights people against the move to
responsibility okay because your rights
are part of what you have by virtue of
being human not by virtue of your
character and not by virtue of your
deeds okay so that's the dilemma we face
that that the human rights community
believes in I share it that one has
rights by virtue of their humanity not
by virtue of you know having prove
themself worthy of Rights and if I go
there where you went
I at least friend it see to my audience
I destroy my argument okay so we can but
we can still talk I'm just saying we can
still talk but I can't talk in that way
that people become worthy of Rights via
the performance of responsibilities okay
but but let's talk I think character is
good to talk about so part of you know
we're saying that this is this still
practicing responsibility and practice
responsibility collectively is a way
that I think people do do build
character and they maybe help their
communities build character right
because some of us you know so and you
know we're going to some of this notion
that we that it's kind of bad manners to
talk about responsibilities
this notion of like you shouldn't talk
about it you should lead by example and
not talk about there's something pudding
and and I think we have to get a little
beyond that this notion that you
shouldn't talk about responsibilities we
have to find a way to talk
responsibilities that's not preachy
right but it has to be more than leading
by example and there's a lot of good
exist this example is I'm going to talk
I will say this on and in two days but
you know young people for example have
figured out responsibility for drunk
driving a lot of them you know they
figured out a way of saying I'm
responsible today I'm not drinking I'm
driving and guess what you're
responsible tomorrow because I'm going
to do this not drinking stuff all week
you know and so the end you may not
consider that character but that's it
that's character okay and that's people
that's young people yeah but that's
young people willing to try to instruct
their peers about what a good member of
the group does they step forward and
they do their share okay and and so I do
think that that in more public
discussion responsibilities could be
good for helping to build character and
we have and I think we do have to escape
in this feeling that you know you really
shouldn't tell people what to do because
that's it's rude it's rude or it's
whatever
see another kind of tension with the
social connection to my church right so
if it's a social connection model of
responsibility that suggests that I have
more responsibility towards the people
with whom I have social connections and
climate change puts that in Nice
perspectives
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
so one I should say that and I probably
did explain this well enough that her no
social connection is the connection to
the problem were socially connected to
the problem not necessarily the
community and so she does a brilliant
actually a brilliant chapter on housing
as a structural injustice as in which
many of us are are socially connected to
the problem even though nothing we've
done makes us kind of how guilty of the
modern housing so you know Cambridge
Massachusetts you know it's you know in
incredible homelessness because of our
housing market right and a lot of us are
implicated we're socially connected to
it even though we can't be said you know
we're to blame for it and so it had
social connections about connection to
the problem everyone socially connected
through the problem not to the community
having said that you've asked a
brilliant question I and that is this
this this conflict between universal
responsibilities and individual and
that's kind of why I like Young's notion
that responsibility is still
discretionary and open-ended in other
words and so and and many of us live
lives of responsibility where we do have
an inner circle it's our family our kids
our parents where we feel a greater
responsibility and then you know and I
don't think there's anything this
counseling model that says no you must
have equal equally responsible to all
members in fact I almost wanted to talk
about in the talk about the rescuer
literature right because the rescuers
rescues during World War two especially
but in Ronda and elsewhere you know have
this amazing characteristic
having exercised great responsibility at
a time it was quite dangerous right and
so they're kind of models of this
responsibility and yet if you read all
in a no lean ER and Kristen Monroe and
other people who written about the
rescuers that children of rescuers are
sometimes a little worried about what
happening they were worried about what
happened because the children was
sometimes put at risk the families their
own children put at risk and the
children often knew that they knew that
their parents were making no distinction
whatsoever between the neighbors who
needed help in their children okay and
so you might say that they live that
life of AB universal duty no distinction
but I don't believe that a
responsibility model calls upon us to
live that life okay and as I think it's
entirely appropriate this model that we
would see that we might have but what's
not appropriate is to see I only have
obligations to my community and none
other right but not that I might do more
for my children or my parents then I'm
gonna do for you know the neighbor next
door yeah
you know I don't know and that's Harvard
swear right that's what I walk past
every morning the truth is I've been
walking through Harvard Square Grassley
and saying what is my responsibility to
homelessness in in Cambridge because I
walked past it every day yeah um yes
central vigor generations so here we
have no obligation as a very center of
you were obligated to view your
obligations mm-hmm
behind the veil of mm-hmm and the state
is the preeminent for fulfilling this
obligation California is a state the
United States is a state the
collectivity of states are states and
the aim says Rawls is the difference
and there are lots of other people the
is to organize the basic structure of
society that is to say the things that
you're just born into like your genes
who your parents are how how rich they
are education system you're in the
initial distribution of wealth etc those
are things which you if you're if people
are going to take responsibility for
them in a central way it's through a
stage so when Donald Trump is failing
the most appropriate thing to do is to
check them out and or not to waste your
time depends on a five about twelve
people on Twitter but mobilize them so
we can kick about and orient yourself to
the only organization that could
possibly work to reorganize things in
the basic structure then and this is the
other side simple people then should
have that was right to take
responsibility for the meaning of the
roadblocks and if they want to spend all
their time with their families
or with their churches then they have a
right to do that this is called banana
in the veil language of the philosophy
deontological activist liberalism now I
was young it's anti that mm-hmm but that
debate rather than there's taking one
side thing that debate is 45 yeah
they're just and to sort of push it all
together which is what you were doing
one I'm not a philosopher I'm not
pretending to be a philosopher and I'm
speaking to a very specific audience
which are people who work in the air of
human rights and who are activists in
the area of Human Rights okay and so my
belief is and this is I'm sorry the
lawyers dirt tune the phosphorus to it
to me
okay is it's a sure if you are if you
are not yeah are you saying that no one
who's not a philosopher can cite a
philosopher I'm taking additional
thought because when I read that I was
grappling with these issues and when I
read I was young I was illuminated
chipping and and when I read on a rant I
was illuminated and when I read monk I
was illuminated these are these are all
philosophers that I found useful okay
so Rawls so but I just want to clarify I
don't think one and this is the problem
if we're gonna have the lawyers tell us
you can't talk about law because you
have an understood law which is what
these colleagues told me when I first
started talking about it you know you
don't understand that law is ubiquitous
that verse also ubiquitous and if we're
loose mostly philosophers tell us that
we can't talk about philosophy unless we
have become moral philosophers then we
can't have an interdisciplinary
discussion okay so Rawls I don't pretend
to be at all and expert of Rawls I did
not go back and reread Rawls why in part
because and I will now if you
adjusted but in part because for people
in the realm of human rights Rawls has
been problematic because of the
distinction he drew between our
international responsibilities and our
domestic responsibilities and so since
anyone working in the realm of the
international protection of human rights
has already moved this is the audience
I'm addressing our human rights people
they've already moved to the notion that
we have internationally guaranteed
rights and we have as a result
international responsibilities derived
from those rights ok and I don't want to
go back to the to the to the
philosophical debate about what are our
international rights and
responsibilities because I'm taking
those as a starting point for my
discussion I'm not trying to establish
that I know international but which are
it he talks about the the great
difference between what he would think
of as the international rights and
responsibilities of versus those we have
to members of our community yes really
interested let me start by saying the
discussion about how conservatives view
human rights is very new to me sort of
rights and responsibilities question and
I was just interested in trying to think
about why your argument about individual
responsibility if I understand it right
wouldn't resonate with conservatives
because it seems to me that the
conservative beef tends to come with
this state that the idea of this you
know writing down every conceivable you
know putting into law or whatever with
sort of a state focus on you know every
conceivable individual action that seems
to be part of the problem and so I'm
just curious
you could talk more about whether there
is a possibility for some kind of
resonance in your argument about finding
I mean you mentioned trying to go beyond
just while the state means to do this
for me or my my family needs to do this
for me that sort of individual piece in
some ways seems to resonate with a
conservative idea so I was just
interested in that I believe that the
issue of responsibilities is something
that could could lead to a broader
argument about our discussion among
people from diverse political viewpoints
okay and so yes I think that's possible
I don't think it's likely it's gonna
happen begin it's partly because we hold
very strongly these notions right
we hope you know so just as I think Mark
said that a lot of left does have a no
responsibility view when it comes to
certain kinds of victims people who have
been victims so the right has a no
apparently and no responsibility view
when it comes to the owners of guns okay
and so I do think that we're going to
need to in order to have this discussion
we're going to open our minds to
re-examine some our own assumptions
about who has rights and who has
responsibilities and whether they're we
should have a realm of no
responsibilities with regard to rights
yes
[Laughter]
that's partly what I'm saying but but I
just would clarify what I'm saying and
that is that and that's what I said
lawyers have said is that for every
right there needs to be a correlative
responsibility or duty right or else
rights won't ever be realized it they'll
simply be the aspirations but I just
want to clarify and this was came up
with my my other answering that is I'm
starting from rights okay because the
danger we start to for me the danger
okay we
start to say there's right source
applications we need them both forever
you know there it's for everybody's
obligation or obligation is right
it makes them us it doesn't necessarily
prioritize rights and I believe and the
reason I'm engaged in this in this you
know inquiry is I believe in the
priority of Rights but that we will not
be able to help people achieve greater
fulfillment of Rights unless individuals
take I think really embraced the idea of
greater responsibility okay so i i'm not
i'm not a agnostic about what comes
first
I believe rights come first and I
believe actually if we we aren't clear
that rights come first
that that's saying rights
responsibilities they both have to be
there they all mix up it's fine
could be it could be produce because we
reach the point where we say that person
hasn't done their responsibilities they
don't deserve their rights and I'm not
willing to go there I'm not willing to
go saying that a failure to do
responsibility means that you lose all
your rights and so I I both agree with
you right on the importance of both but
I'm I want to have an inflection on me
driven by rights last one more and here
it is right there
lawmaker about this particular issue
assuming that they had watched this
conversation you think how would you
basically approach managing gun violence
would you sector that conversation
around the responsibilities of gun
owners and store owners and law makers
or would you question the right to bear
arms well the long issue right you know
as you know there's a lot there's been a
lot of question about what our
Constitution means by the right to bear
arms right and that the current
interpretation by the Supreme Court is
not the only possible interpretation but
that's aside right now we're dealing
with you know I in the in the near
future we're not going to get a
different interpretation of this supreme
court and so I think that going the
right of responsibilities is a good way
to go okay and there's a whole series of
responsibilities that there's a whole
series of policies for example most of
the NRA and many many gun owners refuse
to even think about the thumbprint
trigger you know so we have all of our
phones everything one is a phone you
have a thumbprint you know it you know
you activate it with your thumbprint and
no one thinks anything of it and yet Gun
Owners was something much more dangerous
than a cell phone
beneath in an iPhone we are refusing
apparently I'm not an expert in this
refusing apparently to me consider that
we should have thumbprint triggers a
thumbprint trigger would go away zat
least in a home to keep Missy from
misuse of of guns and then on and on I
mean we've seen you know you see the Las
Vegas situation here's a man who brought
an arsenal an immense arsenal of of
weapons right much more than any gun
enthusiast than any hobbyist than any
hunter than anyone in their right mind
could justify that an individual would
need as part of a right to bear arms and
no one seems to have picked it up no one
took responsibility for figuring out
that this this man was accumulated
immense Arsenal that could only have a
violent purpose so yes I think that we
need that that it's a good it's a it's a
it's a useful route
to begin to talk about responsibilities
[Applause]
[Music]